[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates
dramatic new revelations in the sex
trafficking case against the
self-proclaimed apostle the man who
leads a church that claims five million
members Nason joaquin garcia in court in
los angeles as prosecutors provide new
details of the allegations he recruited
dozens of underage girls from his
congregation for deviant sex acts he
things he's not only an apostille but he
thinks he's living Christ on this earth
the Apostle has pleaded not guilty and
church leaders are standing behind him
plus the US Navy now confirms the
saucer-shaped object seen in videos are
just what many said they were UFOs but
the Navy is calling unidentified aerial
phenomena the UFO debate just got a lot
hotter and our shout out for the
reporters in New Jersey who discovered a
multi-million dollar secret local police
using money to keep their officers
misconduct from the public they we total
up some 60 million dollars spent
allegations of police abuse from the law
and crime Network studios in New York
City's Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates and good evening and thank
you for joining us we begin with new
details in the case of the
self-proclaimed apostle the leader of a
church that claims some five million
members in the United States in more
than 50 other countries around the world
neighthan joaquin garcia was arrested
over the summer and charged by the
California Attorney General with 27
felony counts sex trafficking and the
production of child pornography he has
pleaded not guilty and today in Los
Angeles prosecutors began to lay out
their case against a man who tells his
followers he is the only person on earth
who speaks to God the day began in Los
Angeles as prosecutors turned over to
his lawyers a disc with some of the sex
videos they say they found on the
apostles' electronic devices their
devices that have
content that we've identified as child
pornography what we've done with those
is we've provided defense with a a like
a PDF file of the metadata in the
everything but the photos and videos and
that we've made the photos videos
available to them to review which
they've been doing since Monday there's
also a group of devices that have what
our experts refer to as age difficult
images where there is breast development
but the girls look quite young so we are
not at this juncture in a position to
say with absolute certainty these are 18
or 19 year olds rather than 15 16 or 17
year olds no those are separate because
child pornography means we've identified
them with certainty as being under 18
age difficult means we have not been
able to confirm their identities yet but
we have some concern based on the nature
of the case and the other devices where
we have confirmed it that they may be
minors so without further due diligence
we didn't want to simply copy the images
and provide them rather those also we
handle those the same way as the child
pornography that's not really employment
and so it's a little it's a little
misleading to suggest on this very
beautifully done clean spreadsheet that
all the yes boxes means that we have all
the data we have exactly nothing
we have nothing well I don't think
that's quite you I think there's a
little bit of data that we do have and
all that mr. Mason explain what that is
lawyers for Garcia claiming they're not
getting all the evidence they want
executive producer Rhonda Swartz is in
Los Angeles today to cover the court
hearing and joins us now from outside
the courthouse Ron did seem like a
contentious hearing between the
prosecutors from the attorney general's
office and Garcia's own lawyers it was
indeed and used as you can see the man
known to his followers as the Apostle is
in his orange jumpsuit having traded in
his tuxedo and surrounded by his lawyers
today they argued
that the defense has been slow to turn
over critical pieces of electronic
evidence that was seized in a raid of
his properties the key witnesses in this
case are known as jane doe's one through
four
but what facts their story up is this
physical evidence that the prosecution
claims they have and these videos it's
cell phones computers we don't really
know the full extent it's only been
described as 50 electronic devices
apparently containing videos of the sex
acts themselves that he's been charged
with with underage girls including
forcible rape of a minor and of course
in filing papers by the attorney
general's office they said at one point
he had the young girls put whipped cream
on each other and then lick it off a
sort of a very offensive if true also in
the courtroom Rhonda we see a couple of
women who are charged with him what's
the story with them well you saw in the
courtroom today two of the four women
three women excuse me who've been
charged with his accomplices these are
young women who have been in the inner
circle of the church who are charged
with effectively as of the Jeffrey
Epstein case recruiting these underage
minors they were in the court filing the
Attorney General says that they
recruited minors and had them dressed
provocatively like schoolgirls they had
them put whipped cream on each other and
they described various sex acts that
they seemed to have on these videotape
recordings that they have so one of the
women is still at large
but Susana Oaxaca was in the court today
and I spoke to her briefly she was she's
released on house arrest she has was
surrounded by attorneys wouldn't say
anything very polite shook my hand quiet
throughout neither of the women had
anything to say Rhonda Schwartz thank
you very much outside the court house in
Los Angeles stay on the story all of
this is being closely watched by a group
of former members of the Apostles church
who have banded together in an effort to
expose what they claim is its corruption
greed and sexual depravity
Raquelle Guerra was 14 years old and
living in Texas when she was told by her
church that she had to marry her
boyfriend because they had had sex
they had fornicated her pastor told her
I kind of felt like there wasn't really
a choice because you're kind of scared
cuz you're kind of scared of actually
going to hell because they really really
put that in your head
and she says it became a marriage marked
by physical abuse and heartbreak with
the church indifferent to her plight
maybe it's something that I'm doing to
pray to God maybe to change my ways that
maybe I'm provoking this in some way and
now former members of the church have
begun to organize using social media
including this site on reddit a public
effort to expose what they say is the
corrupt hypocritical and immoral
leadership of joaquin garcia and his
worldwide church she's demented he he's
not right in the head
he thinks he's not only an apostille but
he thinks he's the Living Christ on this
earth when he speaks to his congregation
he literally when he walks through his
walkway
he says you have not received me as only
as an apostle of Christ you have
received me as Jesus Christ himself the
church spends huge sums on its a
possible with elaborate birthday party
celebrations this church in Oregon
hosted a big public
happy birthday video the church has
built a private zoo and rents for the
Apostle in Texas and even as he was
behind bars in California his daughter
was married in an over-the-top wedding
in California to the dismay of many
former members aggravates me because I
know how hard the church members try to
give as much as they can they go without
to be blessed to give such a big
offering and them to do things of this
nature with their hard-earned money the
church insist is leader
the Apostle is innocent of any
wrongdoing and it has told its followers
to pray for joaquin garcia to be found
not guilty church leaders have also told
members to shun to ignore those who
speak out against it what's on your mind
even if it were your brother your father
speaking to them their word in a way
like Angry Men cos it is very dangerous
people nautica recognizes personas the
way works in the church is if you're not
with them you're against them
the way it works that what they preach
is if you are deviating from the path of
the Lord you're you're from the devil
now the devil has gotten you the devil
has done everything he could with you so
your conversations you put you're pretty
much meaningless raquel guerra says she
had to leave the church once she started
divorce from her husband causing strains
with her family I mean we do talk of
course but I really don't have a really
close relationship with my family and
especially probably after this I we're
gonna be surprised if I'm disowned
because you're talking you with us right
now
yes that would be seen as a sin oh it's
worse than a sin it's going against the
man of God you're it's beyond a sin and
voice even oh sorry yeah and so why are
you doing it because I'm tired of seeing
my family just deceived they really they
really don't see it as much as you try
and tell them show them facts they they
refuse to even consider that this could
be a cult again the apostle joaquin
garcia has denied all of the allegations
against him we asked his lawyers and
church representatives to be here
tonight on our program but they declined
the offer remains open as we continue to
investigate this important story next up
those US Navy videos that officials now
confirm our unidentified flying objects
define the law of aerodynamics we turn
now to a fascinating development that
has turned science fiction into science
nonfiction in the movies UFOs flying
saucers have been imagined in lots of
ways over the years but no official
government source has ever confirmed
that anything like this actually exists
until now with a u.s. Navy spokesperson
for the first time confirming that a
series of videos made by US Navy jet
fighters show exactly what many
theorized they did show unidentified
flying objects or what the Navy prefers
to call unidentified aerial phenomena
the videos were first released by a
group called to the Stars Academy of
Arts and Sciences the videos comes from
an encounter by a u.s. Navy jet fighter
near San Diego in 2015 the pilot and the
weapon systems operator used their
advanced tracking devices to record an
object that some analysts say shows
never-before-seen flight capabilities
there's a whole fleet I'm gonna look on
the essay my god
well going against the wind the window
hudson playing up the West
Oh
it's rotated the second video from 2004
off the coast of San Diego was recorded
by a US Navy f-18 Super Hornet jet
fighter tracking an object traveling at
a high rate of speed zooming in and out
and then suddenly accelerating to the
left out of view of the sensors at what
some analysts call an unprecedented
velocity without a sonic boom look at it
again the third video also was recorded
in 2015 on the East Coast by a weapon
systems operator with advanced tracking
capabilities astounding the operator and
his fighter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
those videos have been around for a few
years but it's only now that the US Navy
through a spokesperson Joseph Gradishar
confirmed in effect the Navy has no idea
what those objects are all of that came
from the hard work of our next guest
John Greenwald the creator of the online
site black vault which specializes in
obtaining Declassified government
documents and has been researching UFOs
since he was 15 John thanks for joining
us what do you make of these videos you
know they're very very interesting I
have watched the progression of the
story since December of 2017 when the
New York Times broke the story Politico
ran a story in these videos two of the
three surface for the first time or at
least that's how it was reported they're
intriguing I'll tell you that much I
mean there's something that got my
attention and I wanted more answers
that's why I started pushing and you got
the Navy to confirm that the videos are
theirs they are authentic and in fact
they don't know what you're looking at
there yeah to my surprise they not only
said the videos were real they did say
that we weren't supposed to see them but
on top of that they did go on the record
and say the US Navy officially
classifies them as what they call
unidentified aerial phenomena and so
they can't they can't identify them they
don't know what they are I talked to
that same folks when today at the
Pentagon John radda sure he told me
they've now called him unidentified
aerial phenomena not UFOs - essentially
what he called D stigmatized the
reporting by pilots who sometimes are
afraid to call in a UFO sighting for
being kidded about it or made the fun of
yeah I think that that's kind of the
idea that I'm getting that they they
want to encourage pilots if they see
something - say something and I think
with the whole UFO stigma the the the
idea that if you report a UFO you're
some kind of crazy guy they want or they
want that to go away they want the men
and women that are bravely flying in our
skies to not feel bad if they see
something that they can't identify there
should be a
proper channel so I think that that's
the intent with changing UFO to UAP and
he said the incursions like these occur
occur in trainee areas and that they
continued to this day he says they're a
threat to the safety of the aviators and
the security of their operations so he's
saying there still are more incursions
from aircraft or aerial objects they
don't know about yeah but that's a real
interesting part of this story is the
fact that these are not three isolated
incidents but rather they are three
videos that have come by chance to us I
mean they leaked out and so we know the
story now but they're more and obviously
the Navy is going on the record and
saying hey the these things are not only
unidentified they call them a phenomena
they refer to them as you ApS as you
pointed out but they're also going on
the record saying this isn't it there's
a lot more to this how many more they
won't go on the record
they also issued statements that said
anything and everything related to these
UAP encounters will remain classified so
they've kind of shut the door on people
like me getting that information or more
videos I'll still try anyway through the
Freedom of Information Act but through
the Public Affairs Office doesn't sound
like it's going to happen you're gonna
still keep pushing because you feel
there is more out there are there more
videos you're hearing about well that's
that that kind of would be the obvious
way to to think about this if the Navy
is saying it's still happening and
they're still incursions that are going
on in this day and age with all of these
military bases and even our pieces of
technology with flight cameras on board
there's probably more videos and my
guess is there would probably be a lot
of videos at least in my opinion anyway
John Greenwald thank you so much for
joining us keep up the work I appreciate
that thank you up next our shoutout for
the reporters in New Jersey who
uncovered a 60 million dollar secret to
cover up the wrongdoing of local police
and our shoutout tonight goes to the
reporters at the Asbury Park Press in
New Jersey a small newspaper there's
some very big accomplishments a police
chase in New Jersey led to this fiery
scene the car in flames was not part of
it but was instead driven off the road
by the vehicle being chased as the
innocent driver his clothing in flames
runs from his car for help police
arrived and instead of helping him some
of the officers begin to kick him and
then drag him away the incident was one
of dozens discovered by reporters for
the Asbury Park New Jersey press
uncovering what was a 60 million dollar
secret involving out-of-court
settlements that hid police misconduct
these settlement agreements that we were
reporting on mandate that both parties
remain silent you know if they were to
be asked about the issue they're just
going to quietly go their ways and the
taxpayers end up footing the bill on
this largely without knowing about it
Andrew Ford was the lead reporter of a 5
reporter team at the Asbury Park Press
in New Jersey which produced a 19 part
series called protecting the shield a
winner this year of an American Bar
Association silver gavel award
protecting the shield was made necessary
because of the shocking incidents that
we were covering off of the cops and
breaking news beat perhaps the most
striking is a Neptune Police Sergeant
who fatally shot his ex-wife in public
after a car chase in front of their
seven-year-old daughter
I ended up securing an exclusive
interview with him and detailed the
numerous warning signs that authorities
had for that killing actually mother
eventually I was married to for 20 years
this was an absolute team effort a
number of reporters photographers
editors in the room
were involved in putting this huge
production together it took us something
like two years to get all this done so
this was a sweeping and comprehensive
look at police accountability and
problems in New Jersey it all how many
departments did you essentially pull
records on we filed more than once
requests with every department in the
state that's a total of something like
468 municipal police departments the
reporting found more than 200 New Jersey
citizens were victims of what the paper
called rogue cops including one man
unarmed who died in police custody
his final agonizing moments caught on
tape
[Music]
[Music]
his family sued and settled for $350,000
a fact the New Jersey town was not happy
to see published I think the town passed
a resolution condemning the the the
thrust of our reporting but not finding
any errors in the stories that we wrote
they actually passed a resolution
denouncing you yes the township passed a
resolution denouncing us but important
to note found no error in the story that
we wrote about what happened in their
town
but the series had huge impact including
from the story of an officer killed
off-duty in a car crash I found out that
he was drunk and on drugs at the time
found out that his department didn't
have a policy for random drug testing so
we requested drug testing policies from
every department in the state found that
more than 100 departments did not have a
policy for random drug testing and
police officers this sounds like the
kind of thing that any good local
investigative team could do anywhere in
the country that's absolutely right and
you don't have to be an investigative
reporter to do this kind of work
investigative journalism is alive and
well in New Jersey at the Asbury Park
Press and at the other papers in the USA
Today Network we're all working together
out here and we've continued to have
follow-up stories so stick with us and
we'll keep it going
so to Andrew Ford and his colleagues in
this dynamic editor Paul Dunn pro-c a
big shout out for letting its Frida's
and New Jersey taxpayers in on the 60
million dollar hush money secret that's
our program for this week we hope to see
you back here again next week
you